non-minimalists
i would like to ask you to help me
figure out how
to get amazon specifically whole foods
to stop delivering my groceries in
plastic they are the leading
delivery service of the nation and
everything keeps coming in plastic
and i sent a message to my shopper i
said
please do not use plastic please only
use paper
i am living as plastic free as possible
and they ignored it
so speaking of changing patterns ryan
yeah this is one of the reasons that
some of our malls are dying and so the
reason i thought this voicemail stood
out is
we have a company like amazon in
particular now it started before
amazon obviously right it's just like
netflix killed blockbuster right right
but there were a bunch of other things
that that were hurting blockbuster as
well the red box and
netflix was kind of the final nail in
the coffin and amazon is kind of the
final nail on the coffin for these uh
traditional retail stores yes yeah yeah
for for a lot of them at least right
and and so what we're seeing here is
a company who's able to sort of dictate
their own practices
and how do you get amazon to do
something
regulation so what were this podcast is
about regulations isn't it you're
correct i would encourage you to
regulate them
and actually so i know we're saying this
in jest
but you will have to regulate them but
regulating them on your individual level
means you can't
if you if this is important to you if if
shopping without plastic is important to
you then you're going to have to find a
way
around using it because apparently
they're not willing to meet your
demands and if a business is not willing
to provide the product or service that
you want
you've got to find a substitute right
and the product or service you want
involves a a particular way that it's
packaged right
yeah i will say after we had andrew
mcafee on here who was an mit
scientist i did a podcast with him it
was
one of the few remote podcasts that we
did he's an mit scientist he's an
environmentalist he wrote
the book more from less and he has a new
essay
in wired magazine we'll put a link to it
in the show notes but
he is an environmentalist and he has
assured me that
plastic is not as big of a deal as we
make it out to be
and i tend to trust science and
scientists yeah
now here's the thing i would prefer to
use fewer
bits of plastic whenever possible yeah i
think the message to get from it is
i'm not going to be neurotic about the
small things
when there are much bigger things i can
focus my time
attention energy effort on isn't some of
the lead
i'll have to listen to that podcast
isn't some of the legends oh
uh isn't some of the lead in the ocean
like due
to like some of the plastic pollution
not all of it but like
are some of the yeah like the big also
like the big plastic
island that they have in the sea yeah
yeah so let's talk about that yeah just
briefly
so um and this is again coming from from
andrew mcafee yeah
and he he says hey if you want your
plastic to end up in the ocean there's
only one thing you have to do
recycle it which is terrifying to hear
he's like
he said you know personally i i will
throw my plastic away because i know
that we'll end up in a landfill and not
in the ocean well what people understand
what people don't understand with
recycling is that
they only recycle pristinely clean
plastic
so if you've got like an indian to go
container that's stained from indian
food and you put that in the recycling
bin
yes that's gonna end up not in the
landfill right and it could very
possibly
end up in the ocean and yeah the the
problem is
or this is what this is where minimalism
works really well i'm not about having a
zero waste lifestyle although i really
applaud the people who who live they
try to live a zero waste lifestyle yes
it's fundamentally impossible but
it it's uh if you can get as close to
zero as possible and bravo to you i
think it's phenomenal
but what minimalism does is i consume
less so i produce less waste so even if
i'm
if i do bring some plastic into my life
i'm bringing
far fewer things into my life thus i'm
creating
less waste whether it's recyclable waste
or landfill waste or whatever it is
it's a byproduct of consuming less yeah
so for corinne here i totally agree with
what you're saying about she
has to do the regulation herself she's
got one or two options
options she can continue to escalate
this as far as she can
to get them to stop using plastic bags
but ultimately
amazon gets to decide whether or not
they want to honor that request
and if they decide to not honor that
request in karen if you want to live a
plastic free life or as
little plastic as possible in your life
uh you're
you might have to go to the store
yourself and put those things in paper
bags or reusable bags for that matter
yeah
and or find a company to whom this is
important yeah we
ryan and i we work with our friend
malcolm fontier
on this bag called packed bags um and
and so we we have you know the this bag
that showed up in our documentary people
kept asking like uh where did you
where'd you get your bag and like i'm
like there's only 300 that were ever
made i'm sorry
um ryan and i own one percent of the
bags that were ever made
you're not gonna find one right and but
somehow people just kept reaching out to
malcolm
and so we decided to partner up to make
this bag together we did a kickstarter
for it it's still available
online if you're interested if you need
a bag here's the thing you probably
don't need a new bag
if you do it's the best bag i've ever
used but um
in the whole process we decided like
well we don't want
any plastic at all involved right in the
entire
shipping process and the manufacturing
and so what we did
was we made sure that we're not
packaging this thing with plastic
we and that's really hard because you
they put plastic on on everything
on the zippers yeah around the bag the
wrapping the
everything isn't it unfortunate that
well hey cause it cost us a little bit
more to do it this way
significantly so so it's unfortunate
that uh it costs more to do the right
thing
um but also you could tweet that podcast
sean
why why do companies have to be
regulated to do the right thing or
why does corrine have to be regulated to
do the right thing this is the greed
you're talking about
but here's the other part it's not just
the company
we are also greedy exactly we are asking
companies
i want it for a dollar i want free
shipping i want it in my door in two
hours that's my greed when i'm
when i'm saying i want i want this i
want it now i want it cheaper
that's me being greedy and all the
company is doing
is they are meeting my demand if we were
to go out and demand
more from our companies
then we can start to change things now
how do we do that we do it with our
wallets we have to be willing
to spend a little bit more but if we're
consuming less
considerably less we're going to split
spend slightly more
on the things that are truly important
to us but we're still going to be
spending
way less money overall wow i've never
thought of it that way
so we blame corporations for their evil
but they're just reacting to the demand
they absolutely are
and here's the thing if we if we stop
demanding the cheap plastic junk
yeah they would stop doing it this just
goes back to i
the best way we can vote is with our
dollar yes that is the best vote
corinne i'm gonna send you a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
i'll hold it up here for the youtube
audience if you're watching on youtube
it's the first book that ryan and i ever
wrote way back in 2011 although we
rewrote the whole thing in 2015
and it really involves well it's the
five
what we call foundational values in our
life
but it really shows you how we can focus
on
what we can control and what we can let
go
of we can let go of the rest basically
so so it shows you how to focus on the
things
that are within your control and prove
those things
and then let go of the thing it's sort
of the you know it's a book form of the
serenity prayer
control the things that you can and let
go
of of the things that you can